Justina Machado it is a true honor to
sit here across from you
a brilliant comedic and dramatic actress
the work you do on the show just makes
us so emotional I laugh at all the same
time I made you a profile of dinner says
lonely Catholic nurse seeks big strong
man to fill the hole in her life you
might want to reward that season for one
day at a time yes you get the call we're
coming back what's your reaction I wa I
didn't believe it I was in disbelief
because for so long we weren't coming
back so I think it took me a minute to
realize it was the truth and then I
really didn't even celebrate until I was
on set for the first date I actually see
yeah I had to see everybody and and get
excited again because it was such a
roller coaster it was like really it was
so devastating when it was canceled and
then they were like maybe maybe maybe so
then I finally was like you know as an
actor you just got to keep it moving
short I was like that's sad but I got to
keep it moving and then when they you
know I was like what we're back what was
excited what was your face what was the
face you made girl I don't even remember
prior confusion you're like I want it to
be like wait so here we are on set
season 4 what are we in store for this
season well we have a new couch it's a
new couch we're very excited about that
oh well Penelope finds love alex has a
beautiful new girlfriend we're getting
ready to send Elena off to college
and you know we have a bunch of great
guest stars a lot of friends that came
and and
and came to play with us a lot of great
friends that were very excited about
like like Ray Romano like Adam Rodriguez
I think that's all I can say right now
hey Ray Romano was a census guy so he
did the first episode where he came in
and it was it's really brilliant how
they set up the first episode to
reintroduce the family of course he's
effortless and hilarious and it was just
amazing to be next to him no same-sex
partner no unmarried partner no same-sex
unmarried partner and now we know all
the different ways I'm single I'm very
happy check that off there's no box for
happy penelope we're rooting for this
woman to find love is that happening in
season four yes she finds love she finds
love for season four let's see what
happens in season five if we get a
season five fingers yeah but what are we
gonna see in season four in terms of
romance well you're just gonna see her
be involved with somebody that she she's
really into and so you know I don't
think that we've seen Penelope be really
into somebody for a minute so just she's
just really into it and she's a lot he's
a lot of fun and they have a lot of fun
together and they're perfect for each
other
are we taking next steps um I don't know
we'll see like how serious are things
well they're just having fun okay
okay exactly as a mom you know she's
always got a lot going on talk about
Elena first talk to me about the idea of
Elena going off to college well I mean
yeah we're all excited about her going
off to college and you know she's such a
brilliant young woman that it's just the
journey of of this very tight family
letting go of somebody you know she's
looking at schools that are far away
from she's looking at schools that are
far away from home but we're very proud
of her like the family is extremely
proud of her and of course you know
she's gonna go to a great school I mean
she is Elena
okay well of course it's more how is you
know a whale are gonna react how is my
dad react to you not being we were out
because we really haven't I have to be
quite honest I have
read those episode k and I really you
know I really have I've not read those
episodes so I do know that it would you
know it's gonna be a big change for us
okay and then with papito yes god I I
thought I was there I was like [ __ ] you
don't found himself a little romance ya
got a girl he's got a beautiful young
lady
Raquel justice yes yes so how is mom
handling him being in a relationship we
love her doing you yeah grace we yes
immediately yes it's all about loving
this family absolutely next thing you
know we're eating Lunchables in separate
rooms and Grandma Molly's in a home I
think the first episode just coming in
it's just so tight so funny so great I
mean in every episode there's something
that we're talking about as always but
but this year from what I've read it's
just so funny it's so funny I know but
it's like even funnier yeah the bar is
like yes it's even funnier and so that's
what I can say to you it's like the
these episodes that I've read these
episodes that we have shot are just
amazing and we have eight minutes less
by the way right we have commercial
we're handling we don't even feel it
like I thought we were going over there
like no we were we're at 22 minutes so
it's just amazing it's just the bar has
been raised I think on everything with
everything so I'm excited to tackle
every storyline that I'm lucky enough to
shoot I'm so happy to be back so
whatever they give me I'm excited about
that's the first time you'll ever hear
an actress say that later they better go
check with that one okay
yeah I'd never heard an actress say that
I'll take it anything opens the door
that they shouldn't you walked in on our
he walked in on me as an actress doing
streaming versus going to cable yes how
are you enjoying it what are you finding
the similarities and the differences
well i-i've never this Netflix was the
first time that I was ever on a
streaming situation I'm looking forward
to being weekly yeah I think this is a
show that will do well weekly I always
thought it was a show that would do well
weekly appointment base I just I really
do I think it is because people would
see the show would come out and they'd
watch the show in three hours and then
say when's the next season coming and
then it takes so long to get it back
together and get the stories broken so
I'm super excited about it being weekly
so you're getting a little more
hard-to-get wait a little longer I think
I'm more excited about that than
streaming for sure uh we talked about
guest stars earlier yeah I would love if
you could look at the camera and make
your plea for whoever you're just dying
to see some on the show this seems my
goodness Wow I'm gonna tell you who I
I'm dying to have on this show me
personally Freddy Rodriguez because I he
is one of my favorite people in the
world he's like my brother and we had
such an incredible time on Six Feet
Under and I would love to have Freddy
Rodriguez that's who I want on the show
baby you're such a weirdo sometimes
[Music]
whatever my last question for pop to
save a show like one day at a time that
really shines a spotlight on the Latin
ex community what is that what kind of
message does that send that sends a
message of true diversity a message of
they're really listening not the
diversity that and sometimes we like to
say oh we're this diverse it's this I we
are so underrepresented the Latina
community is so underrepresented and
sometimes when we are represented it is
and the kind of narrative we don't want
to be a part of anymore so to be
Institutes for that for them to reach
out and say yes this is not just a
family a lot enix family is a universal
story about love and family we believe
in these people and you'll believe in
these people too so what they did is
like it's amazing I
we're so grateful to pop and pop has
been nothing but incredible to us we're
grateful to pop I may get more I know
thank you limit and by the way Meredith
and I are single-handedly launching your
Emmy Kim hey I love you guys